The joe rogan experience if they were older.
The older I get,
the more grading it becomes.
When you realize you're being protected from destroying yourself,
it's like,
stop it.
Let me,
let me do this.
If this is what I'm compelled to do.
Well,
especially when it's been proven that the things we're trying to prevent you
from doing aren't harmful.
Oftentimes like pot,
just thinking about the money that's been spent on keeping pot illegal.
Of course everyone distrusts here now.
They're never going to listen to a God damn word.
He said he tried to keep pot from them.
Like why?
What's one of the dumbest things the government has ever done is try to keep pot
from people.
No,
because you'd smoke it.
You find out it's awesome.
You don't die.
And then he started distrusting everything.
Right?
Well,
masturbation.
Think about how many people thought they were going to die from masturbation.
Right?
You,
you lose your mind.
You get hair on your homes.
But when did that end?
That wasn't my time.
No.
Well,
a little slick.
No,
no.
I'm talking,
I'm talking about earlier at times,
early 20th century,
19th century.
You know,
I remember her that you were going to go blind or any,
oh yeah,
there were,
there are medical books in the 19th century.
Kellogg had this whole thing about it.
You know,
the,
the causes,
insanity,
insanity.
It causes hair to grow in your palms.
You know,
isn't that weird ability?
This Kellogg from Kellogg cereal,
right?
Yeah.
He had a thing.
He was very,
you ever see that?
The road to Wellville people who masturbate,
he had a thing about that.
I mean,
the whole thing with corn flakes,
the reason corn flakes were invented was to stop boys from masturbation.
How was that?
How was the idea behind that?
We to explain this to us before,
and the idea is that spicy foods excite the sensibilities.
And so if you eat something that tastes interesting,
you're going to want to come.
So they embed and also Graham crackers.
Graham was another of these big ante,
masturbation evangelizers.
So they invent these really intentionally bland foods.
They like to keep the teenage boys from jerking off so that when they finger,
they're assholes.
Exactly.
It's like veal.
Keep them in the dark.
So true.
Kellogg just take,
I'm so fucking horny.
Anything spin your finger,
father,
anything.
Just touch me.
Squirt fucking mountain constitution is,
what am I getting now?
Sheds cow could milk itself.
That would be bad.
It can climb fences.
Really.
How's the Calvert does yoga and couldn't reach.
It's on the teats cal.
It's so smart.
It realizes how fucking huge is.
I can just run through that fence anytime.
Split shitty wooden fences.
These keep cows in with.
That's unbelievable.
It goes along the lines of what you're saying is just like,
you know there's all this,
these people who are conservative morals and stuff and they know,
oh you shouldn't do this.
Shouldn't do that,
shouldn't do that.
Because you've been told us over these years,
but yet over the last century or so,
most of those thoughts been debunked.
Meaning there's places where people allow what you're saying is evil.
It's going to ruin society and a society is going to crumble.
People allow this happen and it doesn't.
Yeah.
And so what are you saying about,
cause if like all this stuff where you're like,
you shouldn't pay for sacs.
He shouldn't do drugs.
You shouldn't do all this shit cause it's gets the,
the,
you know,
the God yet in Amsterdam,
all that is legal and there's not fires coming from the skies and monkey find
monkeys,
tea bag and everybody and you know,
just like it just is,
it's been proven that that will,
suppression is not good for people that don't like it.
It's a bad way to raise children.
It's a bad way to raise a nation,
right?
It's just people don't like suppression.
It's really that simple.
They don't like it.
They got upset.
[inaudible] you're another person and you're telling the guy what to do,
telling the guy can't jerk off.
What does that guy I want to do?
He wants a jerk off.
As soon as he gets away from you,
he wants a boat doors and just jerk off and privacy and then feel terrible about
it and then repent.
And you know,
Kellogg,
no sense.
You know,
Kellogg's,
the guy from the cereal,
Kellogg cereal.
The reason why this is you got to read this book,
sex at dawn by sky.
Chris Ryan,
podcast guests,
fascinating guy.
Um,
I've read that book.
I've done a bunch of podcasts with him and Duncan Trussell,
he's a really interesting guy,
but one of the things that the,
he sent me hip to his like Kellogg's,
you can find this online created cornflakes,
created mild tasting food to keep people from getting sexually aroused.
Said that he lived with his wife for like 40 years in,
bragged about having never having had sex with her but kept a male intern who
would give him daily enemas.
That's fucking Kellogg's.
So think about that.
Repressing sexual thoughts,
unbelief,
pressing and actively,
actively repressing sexual thoughts.
And yet obviously fighting off the gay tooth claw and Fang,
right?
Obviously fighting off the gay.
The guy had a male assistant who's
he's case fuck
face boy.
Put a leather,
uh,
paper boy cap on him and uh,
no shirt and cutoff jeans.
Okay,
you see it?
Please do.
Let me do that right now.
Check now.
I mean if you see that guy's face,
just what a great book,
you'll probably get an even better picture of him where you could go full,
full fucking body and then go with the color specific thing.
Make totally get it obvious.
Photoshop make it.
I think it really look real.
I wonder if she was getting Dick on the side.
Mrs Kellogg's.
Oh,
Mrs Kelli was fucking a personal trainer.
They didn't even have post personal trainers back then.
She invented,
invented it.
She'd vented it just so that she could just have somebody touch me.
Did Jesus touch me on believable?
Well,
that's people,
man.
People that are suppressing other people are usually doing it to try to suppress
him.
Something in themselves.
Have you see a grizzly bear out in the fields and they're eating berries.
That bear might just look at Jugo.
I mean,
I don't give a fuck.
It's plenty of food.
He's not hungry at all.
So the build a bear has a belly full of berries and it's just sitting there
chewing along.
It doesn't give a fuck at all.
But if a grizzly bear sees you and you're hungry,
is that the guy?
And you haven't been hanging out?
Yeah,
he looks pretty good.
Kellogg mean Kellogg.
I like your chest tattoo.
Very Brock Lesnar,
the new thing I'm working on.
Um,
he says,
thank you dude.
Jesus Christ.
What do you need?
Okay.
Key there.
I put it.
Okay.
Stop.
Yes,
and then you're paying.
That's enough.
Let's,
okay.